hi I'm RIA I'm a pasty producer today
I've been challenged to take a come on
food and make it fancy but first I have
an exciting announcement we can merge if
you like the shirt check out the link in
description let's see what we are making
fancy today chocolate plane I've never
had this before so in Japan we have
pudding but it's a little bit more farm
the guy have tried something like milk
chocolate snack in the state and I felt
like I was betrayed it was too sweet and
it wasn't good
squishy I was told by someone you know
crew he used to use this lid as a spoon
so I want to try that it's not bad I
expected what but it's not - I thought
it wasn't to sleep but there's like
after not that holding my tongue very
sweet
visually it's not pleasing it's just a
Boop we can fix that okay I will call
some great ideas and I'm excited to make
it hey guess what I got
heavy cream dark chocolate X oranges and
dried orange slices from the pantry I
got sugar powdered sugar flour butter
cultural vanilla extract salt milk
cinnamon sticks star
Grand Marnier okay let's get started
make it fancy first step I'm simmering
water and I'm going to need 6 tbsp of
butter
cut it small cubes done in a bowl I'm
using dark chocolate because I don't
want to make it overly sweet gonna do a
rough chop chocolates a little hard so
it's kind of tiring chopping put them in
a bowl put on top of the simmering water
and I'm gonna just lay melt this method
called a double broiler your simmering
water in a pot put a bowl on top of it
and melt so it doesn't give a direct
heat you won't burn anything inside of
the ball why do we are waiting to
measure our dry ingredients 1 and 1/2
cup of flour 4 tablespoon of sugar 1/2
teaspoon of salt and set aside
we move on to next step chocolate and
butter mix it's nice and melted and take
off from the heat I'm going to walk on
the wet ingredients while it's cooling 2
cups of milk in 6x teaspoon of vanilla 1
tablespoon of Grand Marnier whisk well
to combine
add this webmix into this flour mix
little by little I tend to use higher
proof alcohol for baking I like using
wine or sake for cooking and I like
using brandy cognac or rum for my baking
this butter is ready I'm gonna set aside
butter and a chocolate mix seeds well
melted chocolate pudding it's very
creamy no right so nice and shiny in a
mixture before you put pudding into
chocolate and butter mixture make sure
it is cool down like room temperature
otherwise sometimes it separates I want
to make sure this butter is very smooth
so I'm going to pass through mesh sieve
I have to rest this batter for two hours
to overnight and I'm going to keep this
in my refrigerator okay next step you
use two and a half cup of heavy cream
and three tablespoons powdered sugar
when you're making whipped cream total
sugar melts better usually I like to use
whisk but two and a half cup is a lot so
I'm going to start with Honda mixer and
kind of control the consistency later on
with this is almost done so I'm gonna
stop right here switch to whisk so I can
finish what I like it's nice of peak I'm
gonna add one and a half orange zest
when you're using orange zest you don't
want to use like white part it kind of
bitter so make sure just using orange
part and I'm going to use vanilla
pudding
gently fold
when it comes to ice cream I don't know
I like boss it just depends on the mood
when your ice cream uses best
ingredients whoever said vanilla it's my
favorite
I respect to your palate right so we are
going to keep this in the fridge until
we use it so butter is rested I'm going
to start cooking and I have 1.5 ounce
little quickly so you kind of wait until
the edge is crispy and surface is a
little bit drier see off the edge once
it's cooked you want to kind of flip
that sear for like 20 30 seconds done
only you just have to keep doing this
until you are running out of butter when
you're making crepe you want to make it
super thin like paper thin and make sure
to use the nonstick pan okay so I'm
going to finish all the butter and I'm
going to cook rest of the crepes so I
have stuck on my crepes here and I have
my orange cream ready so I'm going to
assemble and I have cake round it's
easier to transfer and I'm going to use
a little bit cream as a glue for one
crepe you it's like quarter cup cream
each time you're gonna just spread when
you're spreading cream offset spatula is
very convenient tool so you can evenly
spread the cream right pan down I'm kind
of keep doing the same thing layer of
creep and another layer of cream and
keep stacking them
okay so final stretch I have one more
left
nice we have to chill this for 30
minutes and we are going to next step
I'm going to use one cup of heavy cream
and while it's heating up I'm going to
chop a unseats chocolate it's not as
maybe fun as it looks kind of hurt your
hand
so the sous-chef thought I was frying
sushi in oil and I noticed there was
like some burn mark but you know as I
mentioned I don't even remember what
they're like ex-boyfriends right it all
sits a lot right now you only live once
if you start seeing the little bubble
around it it's ready pour over into
chocolate you want to wait one to two
minutes because if you start whisking
right away chocolate it's not warm
enough you cannot melt well okay so it's
nice and melted I'm adding four
tablespoons of corn syrup so we can give
a little bit shine one tablespoon of the
Grand Marnier I'm adding another
chocolate pudding this is all it's
chocolate pudding for adult you can give
this choke opening for your kids and you
can make this for yourself it's nice and
shiny so this is done and I'm moving on
to next step we got this from the fridge
and it's nice and chill and I'm going to
give a haircut so it's gonna be a ball
car I'm gonna just trim the edge as I go
smooth the surface we gave a nice bokeh
I'm going to pour ganache over so I want
to put something underneath it so it
drips through
[Music]
thank you
final touch going to cut in a half I'm
going to put cinnamon stick on top kind
of alternate and I'm done
[Music]
supersoft
[Music]
it's super fancy welcome to odds mean
thank you for make you fancy you me make
it sexy that's right so do you wanna
have a bite
yes is this my slice why do you like it
Wow smells very good smells delectable
look at that losing cream
[Music]
I think I'm in love with you yes thank
you can you guess why I made fancy sexy
this time my first thought is oranges
cinnamon chocolate pudding are you
serious yeah I also used bunny operative
modeling yeah Wow
it tastes amazing it tastes like it
belongs in a Michelin star restaurant
also it's kind of shiny so if create
looks into it becomes prettier because
it's like a mirror hello make a fuzzy
welcome Ryan to chocolate pudding one
down sharp wit pudding at Wonderland
I love chocolate pudding oh I really do
good and I like your mug I like my mug
to make it fancy let me eat it
yeah that's great so I'm assuming that
there's gonna be orange and cinnamon
flavors and I know it's a bunch of
crepes stacked on top of each other with
cream in the middle yeah is it called no
in French yes but in English crepe cake
yeah but we just made a new name for
this it's Craig Craig Craig Raymond cake
so it's great
I like Craig I love all things creamy
like cream in general you know make it
fancy thank you so much for watching and
let us know what I should make fancy
next time don't forget that I'll make it
fancy
[Music]